que roger marion ancien chef de la
division nationale antiterroriste
bonsoir roger marion merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france on va on
va aborder le volet policier à présent
votre votre réaction tout d'abord sur
cet acte commis avec une arme blanche
par un jeune homme de 18 ans savent ça
vous paraît invraisemblable ou pas ce
soir c'est à dire que nous sommes dans
l'horreur et malheureusement ce sol et
les moyens utilisés par les activistes
islamiques n'est ce pas qui pratiquent
l'égorgement et donc on sait on en a
connu déjà une décapitation ces matins
fallavier dans l'isère lorsque le chef
d'entreprise a été décapitée que sa tête
a été mise sur sur la grille de
l'entreprise donc vous savez on est dans
la rondelle à l'horreur s'est hissé à la
limite il imaginable de ce ce ne sont
pas des actes que ce sont des actes de
barbarie plus tôt n'est ce pas ce mode
opératoire selon opératoire on l'a connu
au moment de des groupes islamiques
armés en algérie n'est ce pas et puis
cette cette violence était et emporté
sur notre territoire
m ce modus operandi dans le contexte il
faut le rappeler dans le contexte du
procès des attentats de 95 quelques
quelques jours après me plusieurs jours
après l'attentât qui a eu lieu sur
vis-à-vis d'eux de deux journalistes
journée sur les lieux deux
les locaux de charlie hebdo n'est ce pas
donc avec cette menace santé menace
terroriste dans ton de ce dont on ne
peut plus séparer maintenant et qui est
prégnante sur notre territoire mais ce
qui est ce qui est grave
comme le soulignait cet enseignant qui
vient à juste titre de ton peut dire que
aujourd'hui c'est plus que la liberté
d'expression qui est un qui est attaqué
c'est cesser de la liberté de la saison
la liberté d'enseignement et la scène
c'est le fondement de nos valeurs comme
si nos enseignants ne peuvent plus
enseigner nos valeurs et en se référant
à l'histoire à notre histoire
c'est à dire on attaque notre culture
l'attaquent notre civilisation
et comme il l'a rappelé dans son sang
arabe nous sommes aujourd'hui place les
valeurs passent ainsi quà de la charia
au dessus des lois de la république
donc on est dans une situation où venir
parler de séparatisme à la limite
munitis par rapport à la réalité des
situations que deux rivaux qu'il peut
être l'amour comme tout ce que nous
avons comme arme
cela me battre pour combattre parce les
lions alors avec quoi est ce qu'on peut
se battre justement contre ce genre
d'actes et de terrorisme vous dites on
est en guerre mais comment se battre
contre un individu isolé et coûté 4
d'opérations extérieures avait nos
armées et il faut il faut savoir aussi
quel sacrifice ils font c'est le cas au
mali c'est le cas ça a été le cas de la
coalition parce que l'état islamique
vous savez ça a été la première
organisation terroriste qui a réussi à
avoir une implantation territoriale a
réussi à mettre fin à cette à cette zone
sont si vite nous avons nous avons des
activistes conditions qui sont disons
artiste non un sable sur les rites use
and europe et autres qui se tient au
plan quitter les théâtres d'opération
n'est ce pas et qui ici que c'est une
race dépendamment de tous les activistes
qui ont été peu ou pas condamné et qui
aujourd'hui sont recouvrer la liberté
c'est bien combler les armes juridiques
que nos avions
à une certaine époque cela peut les
appeler ça la fierté great à l'espace
avec des moyens des moyens juridiques
l'arsenal juridique dont la loi de 1986
inspiré et comme vous l'avez dit 2015 on
a économisé leur inculture l'état
d'urgence donc il faut des moyens
exceptionnels
vous savez que tous les services de
renseignements et entrevues été
considérablement renforcées autour des
moyennes de la ducati ton risque qui
l'armement
parce que c'est qu'il faut ce qu'il faut
souligner c'est quand même la rapide
c'est la police municipale roger marion
c'est la police municipale qui a donné
l' alerte ça pose aussi la question
peut-être de l'armement de la police
municipale face à ce genre de situation
opéré aujourd'hui le fait de s'appeler
besoin que gérard collomb à la plus de
besoin même caractère troisième tour que
gérard collomb et les frais et rieur
alors qu'on appelle le code client de
sécurité ont tenu à la coproduction de
sécurité les services de sécurité de
l'état police et gendarmerie
les polices municipales et l'a
construite et prier donc c'est ça qu'il
faut développer parce que vos nombreux
qu'aujourd'hui les forces et des
structures itesoft comme borg n'est pas
réel vent revient à cordes à leur
redonner des moyens de cotiser se réfère
à contre a auparavant
le constat aujourd'hui qu'il est fait
également dans les halles dans les
années 2000 lorsque pierre joxe était
mitraillé derrière et qu'il avait comme
plan
un plateau tma-21 bizarre de donner des
moyens supplémentaires la police et j'ai
beaucoup de mineurs on peut toujours
rêver ne compte pas j'ai mario est ce
qu'on avait bts qu'il n'y avait pas des
signes en tout cas pour montrer la la la
menace qui pesait sur ce professeur des
parents s'étaient plaints qu'il est
qu'ils aient montré à ses élèves des
caricatures de mahomet à partir de ce
moment-là ça remonte pas au service de
renseignement ce genre d'agissements et
cette menace potentielle qui pèsent sur
ce professeur elle peut remonter plus
présentable et les établissements des
références n'est ce pas donc normalement
les chefs d'établissement l'information
remonte au niveau des chefs
d'établissement qui sont à même ils sont
à même de faire passer le message aux
référents police-gendarmerie ferme
police ou gendarmerie
n'est ce pas quel que doit faire ce soir
emmanuel macron qui est attendu sur
place
quelles paroles vous attendez de 1,2 sa
part je ne le suis pas l'itium répondre
à cette question
attendons de voir ce que le prédire
marion en tout cas d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce soir sur arte france